there's a video of an Easter Bunny
appearing grabbing Joe bidening him away
when he was starting to talk about
Afghanistan knowing oh crap he can't
talk to the media Fox News Easter Bunny
whisks Biden away as he starts
discussing Afghanistan video that's a
real thing that happened and literally
we are having hired actors Easter
Bunnies acting like the media Liaisons
making sure that the president of the
United States does not get to openly
speak with the press and and the media
you can't script this stuff look at this
video Let's play it look at what's he
doing
[Music]
[Laughter]
not happening that is crazy it's not Joe
Biden that should get played every time
that that Joe Biden speaks that should
be played right afterwards so everyone
knows exactly what the score is and all
you could kind of make out was like
Pakistan Afghanistan they're like did he
say Pakistan let Easter Bunny yeah let's
get over there the Easter Bunny is
standing there and then like looking
around and then you know CIA guy is like
or FBI the president's going off script
bringing the Easter Bunny and the Easter
Bunny is like copy copying these money
like goes in waving and but for real
that's probably what happened yes that's
literally what happens
someone had to tell the Easter Bunny to
go and stop him from speaking to people
can you imagine in his mind he's like
God these people are everywhere
I finally got away I finally could speak
to the Press I finally got to say
something no the Easter Bunny comes in
you guys ever watch like Mr Magoo yeah
where he's like blindly bumbling about
and then he like walks on the I-beam and
gets lifted up and then walks in like we
need something like that of Biden I mean
it's like the CIA being like Oh
he's on the move I mean you could just
take Biden's face and put it onto an
existing cartoon of Mr Magoo doing all
that stuff and it would fit fine
I've always been a fan of the ghost
handshakes you know he turned yeah
thank you it's funny because I feel like
uh I always reference what was it um
what was the movie where the with the
the person's riding the the gravity bomb
down like yeah that goes out of the
plane or whatever
yeah that's what it kind of feels like
you know when we're sitting here
laughing about what Biden is we're like
it's so funny and it's like everything's
on fire and we're talking about how
funny it is it's like uh maybe we should
be I don't know I guess what can you do
you can laugh you can laugh every cry
yeah there's a cry about it 100 there's
a lot of people that you know get upset
about things that they read and stuff
and it's like look you can be angry
about it but it's not gonna change it
like you so are you getting upset about
something that you saw on the Internet
isn't going to change the conditions in
the world one bit and I mean like I'm
not super stoic but I do like follow
like stoicism pages and that's one of
the things that Stokes talk about like
only let the things that you can
actually change affect you and like the
things that you can't change like just
try not to let them ruin your day
because you can't do anything about them
you know you I think uh you want to just
focus on building your skills
uh get learn some outdoors kind of stuff
I'm not telling you to become a prepper
survivalist I'm saying you know learn
how to make a fire I'm saying become a
prepper survivalist I'm saying with the
way things are going and especially with
what the pope has been saying especially
with the way that everything is moving
become a survival and what'd the pope
say uh the pope said that he had an omen
of even greater destruction and
dissolution for mankind I want to say
that I was raised Catholic and as far as
I know Catholics getting Omens is some
demonic kind of stuff that is like
heresy or like that like that's
blasphemy I don't think that Catholics
are supposed to be getting Omens that's
like yeah well this is the lgbtq woke
Pro immigration Pope as well that's a
weird Catholic you know yeah he's the
woke Pope so
um but again I don't think his
assessment is wrong especially if you
look at how international relations are
shaping up especially when you look at
the larger Financial picture especially
when you look at the overall health and
population decline in Crash that's
coming I think he's absolutely really I
don't know anything you guys should
prepare you guys should be smart you
guys should be making moves in your life
where you're becoming the strongest best
versions of yourselves because you will
be tested and hard times are ahead of us
there's no denying this because we are
having too many weak men creating really
bad times those bad times are going to
be upon us very soon have you guys
watched the show the peripheral I have
so there it's like there's they call the
jackpot when all of the like all of the
problems that everyone's talking about
happen all at once basically over the
span of a few years and I think they
were saying like it starts in 2028 with
the Texas secessionist movement or
something obviously they're they're
being inspired by the news and stuff
we're seeing today but it was it was
interesting to see nonetheless that
maybe there's some kind of potential
there that the fourth turning suggests
2028 is the crescendo or whatever it may
be 2026 because 2028 is when it's
supposed to stop or something like that
or who knows I don't know if those
predictions are completely true it's
just people have ideas but considering
what we're seeing around us I'm I'm
seeing every so often you'll get you'll
get some commenter commentator be like
oh you know what I realize things aren't
really that bad and then you see like
project Veritas expose a school for
passing around adult toys to children
and then
politically people like the school is
actively defending it saying it's okay
and I'm like all right you know that's
the demonic stuff because when you're at
the point where the school is like you
know what we're not even going to try
and hide it anymore we're going to
outright just defend it the outright
defend it it's like we're off the line
we're over the cliff We Are Free Falling
at this point so I don't feel like 2026
is too too big a an ask to say that's
when things you know pop up I'm not
saying literally ask I'm saying it's not
too too uh far of a uh too far-fetched
to believe yeah absolutely not I mean I
started my own prepper apocalypse class
online I started doing them in New
Hampshire and a lot of people were
really interested in it because I I
think you know even if it's not you know
political disasters I mean the chances
of natural disasters are also out there
the the the chances of just something
bad happening is always out there no
matter what being prepared for it makes
you not only have peace of mind but but
also has you ready for almost anything
coming your way and I think this is the
kind of mentality that could actually
Safeguard us a lot of stress have us not
freak out have us not lose our ish but
also more importantly Go Back To Nature
and understand the importance of
personal responsibility taking care of
ourselves and not needing a government
to step in and have a food delivery or a
water purification delivery system but
having that in place already where if
times do get really hard you won't need
more government you will need more space
you will need more freedom and I think
once we incentivize that and start
pushing those larger ideas out there
Society by and large will become better
because of that well and that's actually
an interesting part of the show right
kind of post jackpot it's massive
massive government control right I mean
they're controlling I mean literally
what people think what happens in
society and I mean to your point on the
prepper side and this is something I've
been working on in the state treasurer's
office I'm sure you've seen these MCC
codes they're putting in place for
credit cards now to be able to track the
purchase of guns and ammunition around
the country this is a back door uh
National gun registry and this was
pushed by Elizabeth Warren and the Raz
so if you are buying guns right now pay
cash or uh check but this is something
that we're going to have legislation on
in January in West Virginia hopefully
other states are replicated and and it's
actually not the credit card companies
that want to track this it's the banks
the banks want to track it and then the
banks are going to be able to say oh
we're going to flag this so you're going
to flag that you're saying that I got a
Discover card for no reason uh
as soon as the news came out that was
like visa and MasterCard I was like I'm
gonna apply for a Discover Card we're
gonna use it for business stuff yeah I
got one I got it right here I'm holding
it I don't want to show it because it's
credit card obviously yeah and I mean it
is you know visa and MasterCard I mean
they're they're held to the whims of
these Banks and it was big Bank in New
York that have been pushing this and it
has like some Anodyne name the I think
it's the international organization on
standardization
one of the good things about the the gun
culture is the people that are that tend
to be selling guns and firearms and
stuff like that they're usually very
open to cash they're very you know right
sometimes they're open to barter even
but definitely open to cash
um so or 3D printed guns you do it
yourself work too I mean yeah there's
nothing wrong with with printing Guns by
the parts that aren't serialized over
through mail order or whatever and then
you know when it comes to the actual
receiver or whatever yeah just make sure
because I think what was it the ATF was
cracking down on the what what was it
called well there's like you could buy a
kit where it's like all the stuff that
you legally have to have tracked as
tracked and then you can assemble it
yourself but they're like 80 kits or
something like that and then the ATF
started claiming that it was you
couldn't do it you're coming after
people you can buy a whole rifle except
for the lower receiver which is the part
that serialized that has the gun so you
have everything the upper receiver all
of the pins and and everything you need
you can buy that without any kind of uh
any kind of background check during
check or anything like that and then you
can either print a lower receiver or you
can buy it depends on what state you're
in as well because there's oh yeah
I'm talking about where you will get in
trouble for it so make sure you always
look up the local laws and jurisdictions
to make sure that you're not entrapping
yourself or your friends or your buddies
with some activities that you could be
maybe bragging about on social media
which you should you shouldn't do it the
the when I what I was talking about was
Federal Regulation not State regulated
yeah so I won't point out in state of
West Virginia there's not too much you
can't do uh that's right yeah in terms
of guns constitutional carry oh yeah
Maryland's one of the few states that
actually banned uh flamethrowers which
is insane it's crazy and California
I guess they were worried about you know
Baltimore and and the DC burbs with
people walking around flames and if I
understand correctly the flamethrower in
question the one that Elon made was was
selling or that caused it was actually
the same kind of uh flamethrower they
used for tarring uh roofs yeah I guess
that you have to have a thing to heat up
the tar or something on a roof and
you'll use that to heat it up so it was
our an existing tool that you know Elon
just put a you know Market in and you're
like oh you can't have that because it's
scary to me now but no I mean to your
point though I mean some level of
individual I mean Independence out there
I mean I think it is important I mean
you know we're talking about the banks
and tracking the gun purchases they
tried to put into uh that big Bill Green
New Deal 2.0 was that uh tracking the uh
600 purchases or greater uh and they
were going to legislate that well then
the bite Administration just turned
around made that a rule yep right so
that's a rule now and I mean that that
is a tremendous amount of oversight so
it was like okay we'll take that out of
the bill we'll get the 87 000 new IRS
agents into the bill and now we'll just
make a rule thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time